la pandemia se ensaña con las aldeas y
pequeños poblados de india en el estado
indio de gujarat los habitantes
decidieron convertir albergues y
escuelas en improvisadas clínicas ante
el colapso del sistema hospitalario hay
13 pacientes en el centro de atención
con ccoo y 19 desde ahora se van a curar
y serán dados de alta pronto el mayor
logro para nosotros es que nos últimos
30 días ningún paciente ha muerto ante
la falta de camas en hospitales este
improvisado centro atiende a adultos
mayores de 45 años más de 80 han sido
enviados a casa totalmente recuperados
pero en otros estados como wood arakan
donde no existe la mínima
infraestructura para proponer centros
temporales unidades móviles de salud
deben subir empinadas montañas para
intentar atender a los contagiados con
los escasos medios disponibles hay
muchas instalaciones disponibles aquí
como puede ver aquí ni siquiera hay
electricidad el oxígeno tampoco funciona
uno de los cilindros está vacío y sólo
tenemos otro adicional
en la remota aldea de pita frontera con
nepal y china los aldeanos deben
realizarse la prueba del cofipe
pero es que va a jugar los aldeanos
tienen miedo de lo que le sucedería si
dan positivo tendríamos que viajar a un
hospital muy lejano y las noticias dicen
que están repletos ya que en ella india
registrado 26 millones de casos y es el
segundo epicentro de la pandemia a nivel
mundial hasta ahora registra más de
300.000 fallecidos por kobe aunque
analistas apuntan que esa cifra podría
ser mayor debido a los subregistros